das leben des achtjährigen mario ist
durch die korona pandemie
durcheinandergekommen durch die
wochenlange schulschließung verliert er
zunächst die tagesstruktur später die
kontrolle über seine gefühle
er kommt in die kinder- und
jugendpsychiatrie der mediclin klinik in
offenburg dort wird der zwei wochen lang
stationär behandelt da kam auch viele
dinge zusammen sicherlich er hatte dann
eine logische störung entwickelt er
hatte massive ängste vor insekten
entwickelt und die eltern haben darauf
dann auch so reagiert zb dass sie die
fenster ab klebten dass auch ja nichts
rein kommt und er konnte aber auch gar
nicht mehr raus gehen also war dadurch
natürlich auch sehr stark eingeschränkt
mittlerweile kann er eine tagesklinik
besuchen kommt am abend zurück zu seinen
eltern nach hause alles schritte in ein
normales leben
das noch vor kurzem für die eltern nicht
mehr möglich schien
[Musik]
irgendwann auch nicht mehr weiter wie
kann man ihn jetzt noch helfen konnten
eine schule nach hause unterrichten es
geht nicht die zahl der schulverweigerer
ist nach dem ersten lockdown angestiegen
erzählt er zu den amelie von dietfurt
die seelischen auswirkungen der korona
maßnahmen auf kinder und jugendliche
sind teilweise massiv sie erlebt
familien die unter extremen stress
stehen nicht mehr da sein können für
ihre kinder
kinder können das ja relativ lang
einfach wegstecken
die einen länger die anderen kürzer und
die sorge ist jetzt meine persönliche
sorge ist dass die zeit einfach viel zu
lang ist viel zu lang schauen müssten
ganz viele kinder und ganz viele eltern
dinge immer wegstecken oder aushalten
aushalten aushalten und irgendwann
bricht es dann auch für aaron waren die
korona auswirkungen irgendwann zu viel
der 15 jährige ist seit zwei jahren
wegen depressionen in therapie
eigentlich ging es ihnen ganz gut doch
dann kam corona und alles wurde wieder
schlimmer zuletzt verbrachte er deshalb
drei tage auf der geschützten station
der kinder und jugendpsychiatrie
dadurch dass das internat geschlossen
das bin ich eben durchgängig zu hause
und das war einfach schwierig und die
suizidgedanken wurden immer stärker und
mehr und jetzt nämlich eben weil sich
auch durch die lockt und so sehr das
verschlimmert hat nämlich seit anfang
dezember auch medikamente kein
einzelfall
seit herbst beobachten die kinder und
jugendpsychiater hier in offenburg
verstärkt welche spuren corona in den
sälen hinterlassen hat und dass es jeden
treffen kann
patienten die neu sich vorstellen die
vorher auch nie in kliniken waren in
ambulanzen waren oder in praxen
vorgestellt waren also noch gar nicht im
gesundheitssystem aufgeschlagen sind die
jetzt aber eben auffällig werden sowie
die 15 jährige sophie die erzählt dass
sie für corona ein aktiver teenager war
der gerne sport im verein gemacht hat am
anfang des lok downs fand sie es gut zu
hause zu sein
endlich mal zeit zum ausschlafen serien
schauen
doch nach zwei wochen gibt ihre stimmung
wieder besser viele dass ich wieder
struktur
ich habe gedacht okay jetzt nutzt diese
corinna zeit und dann kam ich irgendwie
auch mal so auf meine ernährung dass ich
die vielleicht ein bisschen anpassen
sollte an diesen sport und dann wird es
dann aber auch ein wenig zu viel könnte
man sagen
sie verliert gewicht zu viel kann sich
am ende kaum noch auf den beinen halten
diagnose magersucht seit zwei monaten
wird sie stationär behandelt sie will es
schaffen aus diesem teufelskreis
herauszukommen
für sich ihre familie und die schule die
sie in diesem jahr abschließen möchte
gitarre üben einfach so vor der kamera
noch vor wenigen monaten war das für
hanna und denkbar
viele menschen treffen ihre schulklasse
besuchen hanna stellte das im letzten
jahr vor riesige herausforderungen
zuletzt verließ sie kaum mehr das haus
mehrere monate musste sie in stationäre
behandlung das war während des ersten
shutdowns es ist haben alle pädagogen
angesagt dann erstmal total doof dass
mich nicht auf der einen station
schicken durften und sowas und für mich
war das eigentlich auch mehr ein
geschenk das sich auch jetzt momentan
dass wir im abstand halten müssen zu
anderen personen auch in der innenstadt
und sich nicht so viele menschen auf
einmal treffen dürfen und es hat zwar
noch leicht gemacht dann wieder rein zu
kommen so in das soziale leben hunger
leidet unter einer sozialen angststörung
sie ist 13 verabredung zum online
musikunterricht mit ihrer klasse die
verbindung zu den mitschülern nur über
den pc aus der entfernung
diese erzwungene distanz die für viele
kinder und jugendliche eine belastung
darstellt hanna empfindet homeschooling
nicht in die schule zu müssen als
vorteil
ich hab das jetzt schon sechs stunden
zur schule zu gehen ohne auch eine
panikattacke oder sowas zu bekommen aber
trotzdem manchmal fällt es ein paar dann
schwere mann fiel die räume wechselt
oder sowas und deswegen finde ich
eigentlich gar nicht so unglaublich
stimmen dass wir jetzt nicht unbedingt
immer so viel präsenz und
ihre eltern und hund churchill geben
hanna halt sie hat bereits große
fortschritte gemacht dass das soziale
leben gerade jetzt nur gebremst möglich
ist schwierig für uns hat es in der
hinsicht auswirkungen dass wir so
gewisse schritte mit hanna zum beispiel
nicht weiter gehen können wo sie sich
ausprobieren kann sicherheit wieder zum
beispiel den tanzunterricht wird man wo
sie mit starten heute in den monaten in
denen es hannah nicht gut ging war sie
hier
in der jugend klinik clemens-august
wiedersehen mit ihrer psychologin
franziska plogmann patienten mit einem
ähnlichen krankheitsbild wie dem von
hanna haben sie hier häufig corona und
der shutdown haben momentan sogar
auswirkungen auf die therapie
das ist die schwierigkeit in der wir uns
gerade befinden
weil natürlich auch für uns die
möglichkeiten dahingehend beschränkt
sind das heißt eigentlich würde man in
der therapie so vorgehen dass man sagt
man sucht die konfrontation man man
sucht die situation auf die angst
bereiten in der hoffnung oder in der in
dem wissen dass es zu einer gewissen
situationen das heißt gewöhnung führt
hanna kommt jetzt nur noch in größeren
abständen zum gespräch in die klinik sie
ist sozial wieder gefestigt gut
eingebunden durch freunde und familie
probleme durch den andauernden shutdown
sehen die experten vor allem bei sozial
schwachen familien
wir haben auch kinder die in der familie
nicht so gut gehalten sind für die
freunde der schulsozialarbeiter die
schulpsychologin die lehrerin die lehrer
ganz wichtiger ansprechpartner sind und
das ist alles weg und die sind oft auch
so auf sich zurückgeworfen
dass sie zu hause keine ansprechpartner
finden und leiter dann auch so depressiv
ergangen dass selbsttötungsgedanken
stärker werden
kindersprechstunde in bremen
normalerweise ist die praxis rappelvoll
doch die typischen infektionskrankheiten
sind dieses jahr ausgeblieben was grund
zur freude scheint lässt kinder und
jugendärzte wie stefan trapp besorgt
aufhorchen denn die wenigen die kommen
zeigen dafür starke auffälligkeiten dass
kinder tatsächlich gerade kleine kinder
sehr rasch enorme rückschritte in der
entwicklung machen wir merken dass die
zb die kleinen kinder die fähigkeiten
verlieren zu zeichnen
die machen auch grobmotorische
rückschritte dieser kleine patient fühlt
sich ganz wohl
doch viele kinder sind zunehmend einsam
entwickeln depressionen wir haben ein
kind betreuen wir das vielleicht das
krasseste beispiel das ist ein hoch
intelligenter junge der in den
kindergarten geht
und der hat diese diese bedrohliche
atmosphäre der umgebung die ängste der
umgebung ganz ungut in eine akute
eskalierende psychiatrische erkrankung
verarbeitet also zunächst mit
angststörungen und zwängen
katharina dürr ist heute mit ihrem
kleinen bruder hier eigentlich eine
routineuntersuchung doch auch sie ist
besorgt so aktiv körper sozusagen
musikalisch aber es ist so ein bisschen
frauen geworden wäre das zu hause bleibt
dann legt er sich meistens ab mit handy
oder fernsehen
das ist sehr schwer also schlimm für ihn
vor allem sein auge feuer hat der
karneval hat er weil er so oft handy
bekommt hat lasen versteht uns leider
kaum
er hat in dem corona ja inzwischen auch
sein deutsch verlernt eine
rückentwicklung die stefan trapp nicht
nur bei dem kurdischen jungen erlebt
dann sehen wir natürlich hier viele
kinder mit denen wir uns zum beispiel
vor einem jahr bei der vorsorge mit drei
jahren ganz gut unterhalten konnten auf
deutsch und die plötzlich nach einem
jahr mich kaum noch verstehen können und
dann anfangen sich irgendwie
pantomimisch zu verständigen weil ihnen
auch die worte fehlen
entwicklungspsychologin wie sabine braun
schlagen jetzt alarm denn je länger der
lockdown anhalte desto größer die gefahr
der rückschritte
oder die ausnahme situation geht nun
über ein jahr ein jahr ist vielleicht
aus der sicht von einem erwachsenen
nicht besonders viel aber aus der sicht
und ein kleinkind ist es sehr viel wenn
sie sich mal informieren ist das ein
fünftel seiner lebenszeit fünftel der
zeit in der es bestimmte dinge gelernt
hat und andere nicht elias
handballverein hat sich deshalb
entschieden das training ins wohnzimmer
zu verlagern
auch um die kinder nicht aus dem auge zu
verlieren und zum körperlich am ball zu
halten
der xoom wird jetzt ordentlich
geschwitzt angespornt durch trainer uli
durch gezieltes krafttraining wird
außerdem stress abgebaut doch nicht alle
kinder in emilia steam können
gleichermaßen mitmachen dann nehmen wir
auch unterschiede waren teilweise 22
kinder die online das nicht hinkriegen
oder weil sie keinen laptop das
natürlich auch eine sache aber ja da
können wir dann auch nicht viel machen
ohnehin benachteiligte kinder drohen in
dieser zeit noch mehr abgehängt zu
werden weil ihnen die nötigen ressourcen
fehlen mahnt auch stefan trappe wird das
viel zu wenig betont dass natürlich die
kinder und jugendlichen total
systemrelevant sind weil letztlich
innerhalb weniger jahre unsere
gesellschaft darauf angewiesen ist dass
die kinder die jetzt die schulen
besuchen die jetzt in den kindergarten
gehen
die werden die zunehmend älter werdende
bevölkerung hier am laufen halten müssen
zurück beim achtjährigen mario in
offenburg corona hat ihn und sein leben
völlig aus der bahn geworfen
er hatte während des ersten lok downs
starke ängste gegen insekten entwickelt
konnte wochenlang nicht die wohnung
verlassen
auch in der schule kam er nicht mehr
klar die lehre schickten ihn nach hause
in der tagesklinik der kinder und
jugendpsychiatrie lernt er wieder zurück
zu finden in ein normales leben
in der klinik in offenburg hat ihr lesen
gelernt und macht von woche zu woche
größere fortschritte
ärzte wie amelie von ditfurth erleben
schon jetzt wie das stresslevel in den
familien steigt finanzielle nöte der
eltern die sorge um die großeltern all
das lastet häufig schwer auf den
schultern von kindern und jugendlichen
also ich denke dass das immer mehr
patienten kommen werden je länger die
diese einschränkungen sind das quasi ja
dass wir hier viel viel mehr
vorstellungen haben als normal weil wir
es jetzt auch ja schon erleben und
deswegen macht es mir sorge wenn die
schulen weiterhin zu bleiben das dass es
vielleicht irgendwann auch noch schwer
zu bewältigen ist also beispielsweise
patienten die erst mal davon profitieren
dass die schule zu ist weil sie
erleichtert sind dass sie nicht in die
schule müssen das verfestigt sich so
sehr dass es sein kann dass sie diese
hürde gar nicht mehr schaffen dann nach
einer längeren zeit zu hause wieder
diese normale funktion einzunehmen
die warteliste auf einen therapieplatz
ist hier in offenburg wie fast überall
in deutschland lang und im stationären
bereich gibt es zu wenig betten für zu
viele patienten sich auch deutlich zu
beobachten dass die dass die
verweildauern länger sind die krisen
sind einfach intensiver die die
patienten durch leben und die die
belegung ist durchgängig hoch auch die
15-jährige gymnasiastin charles leidet
wie sie selbst sagt seit fast einem jahr
unter der korona pandemie sie hat das
asperger syndrom eine form des autismus
menschen wie ihr fallen veränderungen
sehr schwer
sie hat neue zwänge entwickelt wie
häufiges händewaschen oder desinfizieren
von oberflächen
außerdem fühlt sie sich verantwortlich
für ihre großeltern die sie auf gar
keinen fall mit dem virus anstecken
möchte
der kinder- und jugendpsychotherapeuten
pascal fischer betreut schon sehr lange
autistische patienten
ich habe fast allen erlebt dass der
lockdown der schule für sie nicht das
problem im ersten sinne ist aber die
folgen die daraus entstehen aus der
ganzen pandemie situation besonders die
begleitenden störungen zum autismus dazu
ängstliches verhalten dass viele zwänge
selbst an haft rigides verhalten aber
auch wie gehe ich mit dieser situation
um was wir so mit diesen ganzen
emotionalen bereichen der depression
viel stärker zugenommen haben und das
ist sehr schwierig diese patienten aus
diesen löchern herauszuholen um die
schlechte stimmung während der korona
zeit auf der kinder- und jugendstation
irgendwie aufzufangen hat er cia- thomas
cook zusammen mit seinen schützlingen
ein corona lied geschrieben
[Musik]
wir machen es hat uns echt geholfen so
mit der musik noch einmal so mehr spaß
zu haben und echt darüber hinwegzukommen
dass wir nicht nach hause konnten und
unsere familie sehr wenig gesehen haben
nicht nur hier hoffen sie dass die zeit
der isolation bald vorbei ist
[Applaus]